[Música]
[Aplausos]
había una vez un muchachito de tan solo
12 años que tenía tal pasión por el
conocimiento y el aprendizaje que
llegaba a leer dos libros por día
ese amor por ese aprendizaje se
desarrolla de una forma tan fuerte que
logró convencer a la biblioteca de su
pueblo que comprarán nuevos ejemplares
de libros que no tenía acceso
fue tan fuerte esa pasión que él tenía
que le costaba mucho encontrarse con
otros niños y hablar de los mismos temas
por ese motivo durante toda su vida
sufrió bullying
por parte de sus compañeros y más
principalmente por parte de adultos que
no lo comprendían y se sentían
amenazados
ustedes estarán pensando que están estoy
hablando de mí y no estoy hablando de mí
estoy hablando de una persona muy
especial que se llama y lo más que
ustedes seguramente lo conocen
posiblemente el empresario más creativo
en este momento
y el motivo por el cual decidí comenzar
mi charla hablando de él mi charla sobre
el aprendizaje como forma de vida
hablando de él fue porque hace unas
semanas atrás
mientras me encontraba con mis amigos de
los cuales compartimos las mismas
pasiones
al llegar a esa reunión
yo estaba tan emocionado
que me dijeron que es tu cumpleaños
digamos que que hoy en navidad que pasa
y no
es que sucedió un logro tan grande para
todos nosotros los soñadores
que lo quiero compartir
después de muchos años este joven
soñador al que todo el mundo lo criticó
y hasta sus propios ídolos se burlaron
de él
logró crear un vehículo eléctrico poner
un traje de astronauta y
y mandarlo a marte
yo les voy a pedir por favor que le
demos un aplauso en este momento
porque le doy tanto énfasis a esta
imagen porque yo quiero y les voy a
pedir a cada uno de ustedes que cada vez
que alguien les diga que no pueden no
pueden lograr el sueño que ustedes
tienen le muestran esta foto como
decimos en argentina
aquellos boicoteadores de sueños vayan a
buscarla al ángulo ahí la tienen difícil
ahora sí
él me hizo entender cosas realmente
interesantes no sólo él sino tantos
otros como da vinci y demás
donde el aprendizaje ella forma parte de
la vida una persona desde adentro desde
los principios se define como identidad
también aprendí con el correr de los
años que ningún éxito
es creado como objetivo
sino que es consecuencia de una correcta
capacitación
como puede ser que todos nosotros le
exijamos a un joven de 16 17 años que
defina que va a ser el resto de su vida
porque no lo fomentamos a que aprendan
porque no les creamos la necesidad y el
amor de entender
que aprender es la forma que te genera
la mayor cantidad de libertad posible en
tu vida
un generalista utilizando la definición
es una persona que ha logrado obtener
tantos conocimientos simultáneos que
puede generar un impacto exponencial no
solo en su vida sino la de los demás
en base a este conocimiento que yo estoy
transmitiendo y seguramente muchos
ustedes saben porque estamos en un tel
voy a arrancar con algo un poco más
sensible
que es mi propio ejemplo de vida
esta imagen que ustedes ven aquí
es un dibujo que yo hice cuando tenía
siete años
desde pequeño
yo era súper curioso muy tímido
aunque no lo puedan ver ahora pero es
súper tímido con el chico
y me costaba bastante socializar un poco
porque
no entendía cómo las personas hacían las
cosas que hacían
pero estoy muy lejos de ser hilo ni no
me estoy comparando con él para nada lo
único que nos une son que tenemos dos
piernas dos ojos una boca y un gran amor
a el aprendizaje
qué pasó en la vida de este niño que con
siete años dibujaba y soñaba vivir en
una casa de oro con el signo de los
dólares en la ventana
con una cancha de rugby atrás y nunca en
mi vida juan rugby
yo había sido entrenado
para ser un empresario yo creía que el
éxito estaba en el dinero inclusive de
pequeño
la cosa es que parte por parte día por
día
fui aprendiendo cada vez más
y fui adquiriendo un amor que nunca más
terminó pero si se puso en jaque
el día que con 11 años
no voy a quebrar
vino mi madre me dio un abrazo y yo
sentía que algo estaba mal
a los tres meses de ese abrazo a mi
madre
el cáncer la supera perdón
fue un golpe muy fuerte obviamente
y al año siguiente también se va a mi
mejor amigo nicolás pisciotti de
leucemia imagínense en ese momento que
yo no tenía más ganas de aprender nada
apenas tenía ganas de despertarme eso
empezó a crear un montón de conflictos
en mi vida
hasta el punto
que comencé a pensar qué pasaría con mi
hermana menor si le pasaba algo a mi
padre
fue por eso que empecé a meterme en el
mundo del
emprendedurismo del trabajo y demás
con 13 años ya era profesor de
computación de adultos con 15 años tuve
mi primera empresa
y nunca más deje de construir cosas
el destino hizo que comience a viajar de
muy joven
buscando personas iguales a nosotros a
todos los estamos en este momento viendo
este vídeo
y fue un camino bastante difícil
sobre todo porque a mis 23 años me llama
mi hermana estaba viendo en españa'
tenía tres trabajos coleccionaba empleo
y me dice tenés que volver a buenos
aires porque a papá le quedan pocos
meses de vida
eso hice volví
me preocupé a apoyar a mi padre en todo
lo que yo podía
pero también entendía el sentido de la
libertad entendí que un ser humano es un
animal social con sentimiento de
pertenencia lo repito una vez más
un animal social con sentimiento de
pertenencia la pertenencia nos define
nos hace sentir una identidad y mi
identidad era que el aprendizaje por lo
tanto en honor a mi padre en aquel
momento
perdón
decidí tomar las riendas mi vida y salir
a buscar más gente como nosotros
tuve el sueño en ese momento de querer
crear una ong o ser director de una
energía a los 40 años tengan cuidado
porque los sueños se cumplen y lo logré
con 28 años eso es un golpe bastante
fuerte porque pues ya no sabía qué hacer
pero lo más importante que lo que quería
llegar con este mensaje en este momento
en esta primera parte de la charla
es que esa es esa ambición y ese amor
por el conocimiento y la curiosidad no
solo me definió a mí sino que me dio una
familia
una familia en emiratos a la vez me
adopta de corazón musulmanes yo no soy
musulmán y a partir de ese momento me di
cuenta que yo podía tener una vida
también gracias a ellos yo conocí a mi
esposa con quien hoy estamos viajando
por el mundo en un coche luego de
entender que el objetivo en nuestra vida
es seguir aprendiendo y yendo a cada
país y adquiriendo esos conocimientos
hay una charla de peter diamandis que es
una charla magistral donde él dice
que la humanidad se encuentra en el
mejor momento de su historia
la tasa de mortalidad infantil es la más
baja de que tenemos datos la esperanza
de vida nunca fue más alta
la medicina preventiva va a ser que
posiblemente muchos de los que estemos
aquí vivamos más de 90 años la
tecnología exponencial llegó para
quedarse y para brindarnos un montón de
herramientas para poder vivir mejor
pero también
entre conferencia y conferencia entre
emprendedor y emprendedor
utilizando esas oportunidades que se
hambre de conocimiento medio
me di cuenta de una tremenda realidad
que se nos estaba cenando
y es como el impacto a la tecnología
exponencial
va a dejar cientos de millones de
empleos afuera
entre ellos
los de la gente que yo más amo
porque yo nací en una clase media
occidental latinoamericana capitalista
hay un punto muy importante con todo
esto que estoy hablando
y tiene que ver con esta diapositiva
qué va a pasar con américa latina'
si nosotros seguimos permitiendo que la
corrupción
nos quiten educación nos quite
oportunidades y seguimos permitiendo
que los grandes cerebros de nuestra
región migran
y no se queden con nosotros podemos ver
si ustedes quieren puede nombrar
perfectamente países que han visto
nuestra querida región
donde la corrupción ha hecho estragos y
lo sigue haciendo
esto a mí me duele profundamente y es el
motivo por el cual nosotros decidimos
crear este viaje junto a mi esposa y
viajar por el mundo dando charlas
conociendo otras personas
porque realmente y aquí permítanme decir
la buena noticia porque es muy buena la
buena noticia es que la tenemos que
entender
si nosotros tomamos el un planisferio
del mundo vamos a darnos cuenta que
américa latina' específicamente es una
región que tiene muy baja cantidad de
guerras
es una región que tiene todos los climas
es una región con baja polución miren lo
que está sucediendo en asia en este
momento tenemos no tenemos prácticamente
sobrepoblación yo les confirmo porque
esto lo sé porque lo hablo con gente de
todo el mundo que mucha gente quiere
venir a vivir las américas latina cada
vez más
y por este motivo
perdón me voy a poner un poco más
pasional en este momento si no les
molesta
no soy muy de saco
todos los que tenemos acceso a esta
charla todos los presentes en este
momento
aplicaron para estar acá
si alguien está viendo este vídeo en
youtube o donde sea significa que tiene
el acceso a la información que tenemos
nosotros
yo les quiero decir que en este momento
yo me siento que soy un niño en una
juguetería donde puedo tocar todo lo que
está a mi alcance
y somos todos parte del mismo equipo por
este motivo yo les voy a pedir a cada
uno de ustedes donde quiera que estén no
importa no hay excusas que nos pongamos
de pie literalmente nos pongamos de pie
tomemos las riendas de nuestra vida
entendamos el poder que tenemos por
tener acceso a esta información
y trabajemos juntos para crear un futuro
donde aquellos que no tienen la
oportunidad tengan una vida mucho mejor
les pido por favor de todo corazón que
entiendan la importancia del mensaje que
estamos dando
que entiendan las oportunidades
profundamente que tenemos
y si es verdad que mucha gente va a
perder su empleo
pero de nosotros depende la calidad de
vida que van a tener por una américa
latina más unida y más juntas muchas
gracias por su tiempo